Comme un fou va jeter à la mer
Des bouteilles vides et puis espère
Qu'on pourra lire à travers
S.O.S écrit avec de l'air
Pour te dire que je me sens seul
Je dessine à l'encre vide un désert
Et je cours, je me raccroche à la vie
Je me saoule avec le bruit
Des corps qui m'entourent
Comme des lianes nouées de tresses
Sans comprendre la détresse
Des mots que j'envoie
Difficile d'appeler au secours
Quand tant de drames nous oppressent
Et les larmes nouées de stress
Etouffent un peu plus les cris d'amour
De ceux qui sont dans la faiblesse
Et dans un dernier espoir disparaissent
Et je cours, je me raccroche à la vie
Je me saoule avec le bruit
Des corps qui m'entourent
Comme des lianes nouées de tresses
Sans comprendre la détresse
Des mots que j'envoie
Tous les cris, les S.O.S
Partent dans les airs, dans l'eau laissent une trace
Dont les écumes font la beauté
Pris dans leur vaisseau de verre
Les messages luttent mais les vagues les ramènent
En pierres d'étoiles sur les rochers
Et j'ai ramassé les bouts de verre
J'ai recollé tous les morceaux
Tout était clair comme de l'eau
Contre le passé y'a rien à faire
Il faudrait changer les héros
Dans un monde où le plus beau reste à faire
Et je cours, je me raccroche à la vie
Je me saoule avec le bruit
Des corps qui m'entourent
Comme des lianes nouées de tresses
Sans comprendre la détresse
Des mots que j'envoie
Tous les cris, les S.O.S partent dans les airs
Dans l'eau laissent une trace
Dont les écumes font la beauté
Pris dans leur vaisseau de verre
Les messages luttent mais les vagues les ramènent
En pierres d'étoiles sur les rochers
Tous les cris, les S.O.S partent dans les airs
Dans l'eau laissent une trace
Dont les écumes font la beauté
Pris dans leur vaisseau de verre
Les messages luttent mais les vagues les ramènent
En pierre d'étoiles sur les rochers